salvi youtubers e benvenuti in un nuovo
video e niente siccome periodo natalizio
siamo ovviamente in vena di ricordi c
avere una vecchia location sicuramente
molti di voi avranno riconosciuto a
questa è la location dove ho iniziato
file video praticamente e vi chiederete
perché sto facendo un video in questa
location beh semplicemente perché questa
è la casa dei miei genitori e in questo
momento non lo stanno traslocando e mi
sembrava carino dare una specie di
ultimo saluto a questa stanza qui che
era camera mia e questo era l'anfratto
in cui avevo il computer e montavo i
video e giravo i video manca solo il
quadretto di totò sostituito in questo
caso da un babbo natale veramente osceno
e lieta avrei potuto fare una roba
melensa e malinconica tipo io che tocco
piano piano i miei fumetti con una
musica di sottofondo quindi ringrazio la
stanza per avermi permesso di iniziare a
fare video su youtube
ringrazio tutti quelli che mi seguono da
quando faceva il video in questa stanza
e buon video
[Musica]
salve non li avevo visti entrare in
realtà li avevo visti perfettamente ma
fa figo dirlo benvenuti nel magico mondo
di natale mi avete interrotto mentre
guardavo le fotografie di robert capa
fotografo della seconda guerra mondiale
è giusto permettermi nel mucchio e
natalizio avrei una domanda per iniziare
il video perché state tentando di
rovinarmi il natale il 2016 è stato un
anno terribile per quanto riguarda i le
catastrofi per quanto riguarda le morti
famose e stato un anno triste perché
dobbiamo pure infilarci dentro le nostre
turbe mentali questo 2016 per quanto
riguarda internet è stato anche l'anno
del mai la gioia hashtag maina gioia ma
perché perché non riusciamo ad essere
felici anche nel giorno in cui dovresti
essere felice ci sono proprio delle
leggi non scritte che dicono che a
natale puoi fare quello che non puoi
fare mai io adesso voglio capire voglio
capire quanto effettivamente la vostra
vita faccia schifo avrai il passato un
esame avrai baciato la tua ragazza avrà
preso sei in matematica qualcosa
qualcosa che deve faccia avere una vista
cazzo di gioia che poi questo motto del
2016 io lo vedo soprattutto da da
minorenni ma minorenni da ragazzini tipo
11 12 anni su twitter
me ne sono passati in sottomano un sacco
di account di ragazzine dodicenni che
sei uno di quelli che non hanno la foto
del profilo mano tipo un'immagine di
harry styles con nome con scritto harry
styles lovera underscore 2003 e il 2004
ecco adesso io voglio capire che tipo di
vita di merda abbia un dodicenne che
cos'è andato storto durante il tuo
secondo anno di scuole medie poi state
letteralmente rovinando il compleanno di
gesù siete qui guastafeste che quando
vengono i deputati ad una festa stanno
con le braccia concert in un angolo
perché non qui non ci volevo venire
e non è che esci poco con i tuoi amici
che probabilmente loro ti lasciano a
casa perchè sarai una palla e [ __ ]
incredibile ma oggi sono qui per mettere
a posto questa cosa qua ho capito qual è
il vostro dilemma vi siete stufati dei
soliti film di natale
avrete la videocassetta consumata di sta
roba qua avrete mezzo centimetro
visibile tutto il resto white noise
ma non temete vi aiuto io sono qui
apposta volete cambiare il vostro taglio
mai una gioia con l'astag porca [ __ ]
almeno una gioia è arrivata grazie cari
musa e che iaio toby ma buone feste
natalizie a tutti quanti che beccati
questo
è
voglio impiccarmi comunque o l'ingrato
compito di aggiustarsi il natale perché
da soli a quanto pare non ne siete
capaci e quindi spettava
mi raccomando raggruppate parenti ed
amici alla vigilia di natale per
guardare questi film fa più che altro
perché vi servirà il supporto morale
cominciamo santa claus concord martian
questo è una piccola per la trash del
1964 che grazie a internet come allen
per sempre colpa di x men è riuscito nel
corso degli anni ad acchiappare un sacco
di pubblico ma di cosa parla questo film
ma è ovvio è un classico canto natalizio
su marte ci sono due marziani adulti che
sono preoccupati dei loro due marziani
bambini che non fanno altro che guardare
la televisione terrestre in cui appunto
si vede spesso babbo natale e quindi
cosa fare se non rapire babbo natale e
portarlo su marte
e se non fosse abbastanza natalizio per
voi sappiate che c'è un altro marziano
che tenta di ucciderlo un alieno di
marte che tenta di uccidere babbo natale
pala lalla la afa la lalla jingle all
the way 2
forse qualcuno non l'ha riconosciuto dal
titolo in inglese gino non the way 2 e
in seguito ovviamente di jingle all the
way e da noi il gigolo the way è
arrivato come una promessa è una
promessa
ebbene si questo tecnicamente è una
promessa è una promessa due che da noi
però arrivato con il nome de la guerra
dei papà voglio dire ma perché vi
stupite di una promessa è una promessa 2
se sono riusciti a fare beverly hills
chihuahua 2 va bene anche questo è tra i
protagonisti del film saranno contenti
gli amanti del wrestling perché c'è
santino marella e la trama è la stessa
identica nel primo film c'è un papa che
ha una figlia a cui vorrebbe regalare un
giocattolo che non riesce a trovare
wow non ci hanno neanche prova wow santa
with basso c'è alcun in che fa babbo
natale e che cazzo mi serve sapere di
più c'è alcuno che fa babbo natale
tenere proprio babbo natale lui nel
senso lui stava scappando dalla polizia
e si traveste da babbo natale per non
farsi beccare ma poi scivola e sbatte
per della memoria e pensa di essere
babbo natale c'è alcol anche fa babbo
natale io ci ho messo a posto le feste
prego santa slay se per qualcuno
hulk hogan che fa babbo natale non
dovesse bastare se queste persone si
sono stufate mi vedere film di natale
finire in modo positivo come il suo
bomber for life santa slay è il film che
fa per mori santa slay è il film fatto
apposta per chi ha il cazzo la trama è
babbo natale è l'anticristo
e invece di andare nelle case delle
persone a dispensare regali li ammazza
tutti è quasi come se fosse un dolce un
dolce di un ristorante stellato perfetto
davanti a te la ciliegina sulla torta
che manca e che babbo natale nel film è
interpretato da goldberg lo so c'è
qualcuno di voi bene munito ma che non
sa chi sia goldberg non c'è problema
dalla regia facciamo partire le rvm
[Applauso]
buon natale ma per favore non facciamo
l'errore comune da italiano medio di
scartare i nostri film ci pensa zio toby
non vi preoccupate natale a quattro
zampe massimo boldi maurizio mattioli
biagio izzo più natalizia di loro io
veramente non so chi possa esserlo
due ragazzi decidono di aprire un hotel
a quattro zampe per animali ma non
sentite già il profumo di cannella
dell'area con una trama del genere
guarda guarda che bellino bordi con
quella faccia lì bentivoglio a pizzicare
le guance borja miseria non vi piace
massimo boldi posso capirlo non siete
mai alzati la mattina della vigilia di
natale pensando ma lo sai chi sarebbe un
ottimo babbo natale
lino banfi e cazzo il mio amico babbo
natale e tra l'altro non è neanche tanto
male come film di natale certo è molto
italiano per l'amor di dio c'è anche
gerry scotti dentro per dire ma questo
non vuol dire che sia brutto anzi e se
vi dovesse piacere così tanto c'è anche
seguito il mio amico babbo natale 2 cosa
vi serve d'altro per essere felici a
natale se noi lino banfi gerry scotti
ma le vere chicche le ho lasciate per
ultime tre donne save christmas film che
da noi è arrivato con il titolo ma bacio
e natale da carmen di davis e questa
trama e familiare dunque racconta di
zeus un ex cane poliziotto che tra
l'altro essendo un ex qualcosa delle
forze dell'ordine generico e strano che
non sia stato interpretato da steven
seagal viene adottato da una famiglia
che lo lascia in casa da solo la vigilia
di natale ma proprio in quel momento
arrivano due ladri che tentano di
svaligiare la casa ma il nostro zeus
armato di trappole sull buon dio e mamma
ho perso l'aereo in versione canina
senza vergogna alcuna hanno plagiato
impura dei più grandi classici natalizi
negli ultimi anni mettendo però al posto
del povero macaulay culkin carne altro
sto film ha talmente poco budget che
ogni volta che lo vedo mi vien voglia di
allungare 20 euro allo schermo e
compratevi un cazzo di microfono decente
a e non vi ho detto la cosa più
interessante il cane parla o meglio noi
spettatori abbiamo il grandissimo
dileggio di poter sentire i suoi
pensieri è o no o non è un film da
guardare con la cioccolata calda con
tutta la famiglia sotto le coperte
e come se non bastasse hanno fatto anche
un seguito bianco natale per zeus vedere
se è familiare la trama zeus crea delle
trappole per fermare due ladri a sto
giro però c'è anche una barboncina da
salvare
a e non vi ho detto la cosa più
interessante la barboncina è doppiata da
paris hilton e se per caso tutta la
magia delle festività natalizie non vi
abbiano avvolto con la visione di un
bianco natale per zeus non disperate
perché hanno fatto un altro seguito zeus
e il natale california però
fortunatamente la tav a qui è molto
diversa a sto giro in mezzo c'è un
piccolissimo è carinissimo cucciolo di
nome liv
i due cani infatti scoprono di odiarsi
iniziano a litigare per tutto il tempo
finché non sono costretti ad allearsi
quando due ladri e cercano di entrare in
casa ma porca [ __ ] è sempre la stessa
prova degli altri due e voilà visto
adesso vedo un sacco di film tra cui
potete scegliere a natale e non rompete
con gli ori che dite che la vita fa
schifo ogni volta
pensate che c'è sempre sempre qualcuno
che sta molto peggio di voi
[Musica]
visto era tanto difficile mettere a
posto il natale perché ricordatevi una
cosa non c'è miglior finale delle storie
di natale e quindi buone feste e buon
natale a voi a famiglia alla zia in i
cugini a casa posto da posto zia sa bene
va bene noi ci rivediamo prima della
fine dell'anno
comodo